foreign
Sandy is with us in Nashville hi son
Sandy welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
um I've been agonizing over something
for a few weeks walking around my house
saying what would Dave say what would
Dave say so today I decided to call and
see what you would say about this my
husband wants to buy an Airbnb in
Florida as an investment
we have no emergency fund we have
excellent credit all we do have is the
equity in our house which we do have a
mortgage on
I'm terrified about this idea it would
require a home equity line of credit and
possibly another investment mortgage
loan on top of that
so what you already know what Dave would
say
yes I do I believe and do you want to
know what Jade would say
yes yes yes well I might not be able to
sit on the air but
but
it ends in the word no
yeah Capital you know you're broke
people broke people don't need to buy
investment properties broke people
really don't need to buy high-risk
investment properties in another state
with all 100 borrowed money
leveraged on your own home
right this goes sideways it's got
nowhere to go but bad
okay so let me let me tell you he's been
watching he's been spending too much
time on the internet
yeah yeah so here's what the internet
here's what the idiots on Tic Tac will
tell you okay
that um that running an Airbnb is a
hundred percent profit you're going to
make so much money you're going to be
just bathing in money there's going to
be cash everywhere it fails to mention
that renters that tear up your house it
fails to mention the times that it sits
empty it fails to mention the high
management fees it fails to mention all
of the costs of your maid service it
fails to mention uh the fact that the
local municipality decides that airbnbs
are no longer legal and they pass a law
prohibiting Airbnb in your neighborhood
which is happening in some areas and
HOAs are preventing them left and right
because they don't want a hotel in their
neighborhood which is essentially what a
Airbnb is and uh the things if
everything works perfect the way the Tic
Tac guys say
you're going to be so rich it's
unbelievable but guess what you and I
live in the real world it doesn't work
that way running an Airbnb is a complete
pain in the bahunkas
okay that's exactly what every cell in
me is screaming yeah are you going to be
able to convince him of that she's not
going to sign the deed
I'm praying I'm praying so just no I
refuse to sign the HELOC
the house has your name on it in
Tennessee as well he can't get a HELOC
without your signature
no okay well uh thank
you thank you we'll discuss the marriage
aspects of this but no
yeah all right yeah don't do it because
well you know here's the thing who can
find a virtuous wife for her worth is
far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain
Sandy you have what's called common
sense
you can perceive risk a mile away your
husband has spent so much time on Tic
Tac that he has no idea what real risk
is and how much work and Hassle and
problems this is you can make money
running an Airbnb but you know you can
also make money running a hotel but it's
called a full-time job
somebody has to manage the hotel
somebody has to manage the maintenance
people somebody has to manage the maid
service somebody has to this is not just
found money that you walk out on the
sidewalk and pick up a bail of money
because you signed up for Airbnb because
some on Tic Tac said it was a
great idea it's past
there's no pass
age to real estate as you can get
again there is situations where you can
make Bank on this if you're willing to
go through the hassle and the hard work
and put up with it but it's not as much
as people say it is and it's certainly
not as much as your gross rent
projection is by freaking Airbnb because
all they'll tell you is you keep it full
all the time here's what we can get for
it well nobody keeps it full all the
time
number one number two nobody puts
everybody in there and 100 of them pay
never happens nobody puts everybody in
there and they don't tear it up past
beyond the level of their deposit never
happens so
dad gum man I got a a
Three Degrees of Separation uh-huh guy
that has a an expensive property that he
put and a bunch of
uh
[Music]
characters
went in there and one of them killed the
other one in his house
oh
so I was not expecting that yeah there
you go that's my that's my love of
Airbnb it just went away right then but
that doesn't happen very often but I
mean these characters and this was not a
cheap this was not a house in the yeah
in the wrong end of town or whatever it
is you know sheesh no this is this was
people partying and yeah they party too
hard oh my gosh yeah out of control
so yeah it's uh you know it does that is
that is that gonna happen no that's not
gonna happen right all right but the
point is you're running a high turnover
night to night week to week
rental if this is not you put a tenant
in there and they stay in there a year
and you have an actual relationship with
the tenant so okay so here I am plain
Devil's Advocate as I sometimes do there
are listeners who want to get into that
space and they they don't we don't want
them to listen to Tic Tac as you call it
what do you say
Cash Fort after your home's paid for
baby step seven and understand that you
are embracing two things that no one
talks about when you do Airbnb
High hassle Factor high risk
yeah and so you have to apply those to
the numbers it's the same thing when
some somebody goes to one of these
nothing down real estate crap and they
go I can rent the house for a thousand
dollars and my payment's only 500 I'm in
a cash flow 500. well let me tell you
how that works in the end okay if that's
the case you're going to break even
uh-huh with vacancy
with non-payment with suing to a victim
with fixing the repairs beyond the
deposits with fixing the repairs that
just happened to a house the heat and
air goes out the roof leaks paying the
insurance paying the taxes messing with
it you got a 500 cash flow no you don't
you're breaking even this is what people
don't grasp I have a 500 cash flow what
that means is you don't know what the
flip you're doing you have no knowledge
of how real estate really works my homes
and properties of all kinds are 100 paid
for and I swear I wonder if some of them
are going cash flow then wow you know I
mean it's unbelievable and you do no you
do no Airbnb and wouldn't even get into
it no no Winston Cruz runs all that
stuff Rachel's husband he would shoot me
if I propose Airbnb it'll make his life
miserable and but why is that
it's not worth the risk the juice ain't
worth the squeeze there you go that's
what I want people to get like just pay
cash for a normal rental right yeah
that's what I want why even if you want
to do it you probably could make more
money
net net you would make more money if you
could get it if you have a reasonable
property you'll make more money doing it
Airbnb than you would on than you would
rent it out but not just some guy off
the streets who thinks they're just
gonna yeah net net you would do that but
even if you don't know what you're doing
and you don't know if you're how to be a
landlord net net you'd make more money
but you what you need to perceive is the
extra hassle level it is real